the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night past
Studios I'm Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com and Ryan sickler on all your
social media and I want to say thank you
every week thank you for watching the
show thank you for supporting this show
please hit that subscribe I'm telling
you it's a free way to help the show all
right cost you nothing means everything
to us and if you gotta have another
episode a week then you gotta check out
the patreon it's called the Honeydew
with y'all
and you all have the wildest [__]
stories I've ever heard I say it every
week what are we gonna hear this week
and every week I'm like holy [__]
[__] it's my favorite show to do I can't
believe the stories you all have out
there it's five bucks a month all right
you get audio you get video you get the
Honeydew a day early you get it ad free
you get it at no additional cost and if
you sign up for the year you get over a
month of episodes free all right that's
how it works uh if you're looking for a
new podcast check out an old fave man
the crab Feast it's a storytelling
podcast Audio Only it's something I did
with Jay Larson back in the day today's
guest actually has a fantastic episode
on the crab Feast you should check out
now that's the biz you know we do over
here we highlight the low lights and I
always say these are the stories behind
the storytellers very excited to have
this guest here first time on the
Honeydew ladies and Gentlemen please
welcome Miss Pat welcome to the Honeydew
misspack thank you for having me thank
you for being here it's been a long time
we've been trying to make this happen we
have we've been back and forth them back
and forth I come here and I can't make
it so thank you for being patient you're
welcome thank you for being here
um look I'm really excited to talk to
you but before we do plug and promote
everything you want to promote please go
to misspackcomedy.com for all my tour
dates
um I have a TV show called The Miss Pat
Show on BET plus that just dropped the
third season that's congrats today so
make sure you go and watch the new
season of the Miss Pat show if you're
not familiar with today's show you got
three seasons to get into okay three
funny ass Seasons yeah I've watched it
I'll watch it thank you yes I have the
ET plus because I signed up for all
kinds of packages and I wanted to say
again too I said it to you before we
record him but congrats because to get
even a second season these days with
everything that's out there is huge so
to have a third one's really you're
really doing something you know we we
work really hard uh over there to stick
out because you know BT plus is a new
platform they I don't even think they're
three years old if they three years old
so did you start your first season when
they launched then well day was already
out so they might be four years old so
when we first got there they was pretty
new and so I was a little worried in the
beginning I'm like oh I when when they
told us bet because it was Hulu show
they did it they dropped it and so we
were sitting there waiting BT plus
picked it up and I was like what the
hell is BET plus never heard of it and
then when we got into it I you know I
tell my co-creator all the time I say I
think we at the right place where they
allow us to be us ain't nobody there
that don't understand what it is to be
us in America they understand that the
jokes we're writing and it brings over I
think I know the misspass show brings
over a lot of diversity for bet plus so
you know I was just happy they picked us
up and they rolled with us they let us
go there
yeah what I love about you though is you
jumped in back with all of us a long
time ago Ari and Eric Abrams and those
guys like even before everything got
crazy and popular and you've been you've
been right there in the pocket the whole
time just killing it I'm trying I'm
trying to you know uh it's my first
podcast I ever did was Eddie elves was
it Eddie at first okay was the first I
didn't know what the [__] podcast was
didn't know anything about podcasts
um somebody was one of the one of my
friends was listening to uh Eddie up at
the time he was like I want somebody
with some real stories and he's like you
should try this podcast yo what's a
podcast so I flew out to L.A and I did
it you did and the next thing I know I
was getting invited on every white boy
in the city park
I felt like a hooker I was just passing
me around more stories more stories more
stories well your stories are unlike
anybody's stories I mean and you've got
an unlimited supply of them and I have
there's I have my favorites Jimmy Carter
is one of my favorites I just did that
on Jimmy Kimmel I love it
um shot through the titties one of my
favorites yeah selling drugs outside
while you could look right in the school
Windows this is one of my favorites too
there's so many of them before the uh
school zone no drugs oh yeah that's
right now you can't dude no I was
grandfather to him by the time they
realized that she was even a law I was
like y'all ain't talking to me because I
was here before these little ugly sign
was so here's what I do want to know
because the wild stories they're out
there like what is life like now for you
like
because I know I'm from Baltimore I'll
never lose that chip on my shoulder I
always have my shoulders up and there's
always at least one Finch fist clenched
how how do you adapt to quote unquote
regular life like you said you told me
before you live in an all-white
neighborhood like what is life like for
Miss Pat once you get out of that
lifestyle let's say you're talking out
of the uh celebrity lives lifestyle no
not not the Celeb I'm talking about what
is life like just even if you what is it
like leaving a life of drugs crime oh
all of that like that transition I've
been married almost 30 something years
so
um but now you're telling these stories
and people your neighbors are hearing
this the people your kids go to school
with they're hearing this what is life
like for you I mean everybody's
interested in the stories I don't think
people really judge if they do they
don't say [__] and if they do I don't
care because I don't get any people that
slide up to you at the events or
whatever like I heard you on that dude
we sometimes I they hear me all the time
on Rogan and they love the stories and
the ones that don't like I tell them I
said hey I'm like a fast food restaurant
you gonna pass ten more 10 of them to
get to me so it take your pick I'm not
here to please you I'm 50 years old I
don't give a [__] are you 50 though yeah
I'm gonna be 51 in April I said I don't
give a [__] I don't have time to be you
know like we did a we did a bit uh just
on season three of the Miss Pat show and
we said uh Botox got more chemicals in
it than the Flint River and this lady
was like you're gonna I'm gonna write
into bet for you I say lady get the [__]
out of my inbox and I don't give a [__]
I'm bringing awareness to that [__]
cause they stopped talking about it so
get out of my inbox with this [__]
in this TV and move along [__] yeah
this isn't where you go for your yeah
you know your complaints about Flint
Michigan and Botox yeah so you know you
you have people that that wants to judge
you have people that have they look to
say so to everybody but I call them
y'all say you're mad because you can't
do what I'm doing that's why you're fat
asset behind your computer judging me so
I don't care so you've been authentic
since day one I don't know how to change
same yeah I don't know how to be anybody
different I try to be a better me but
that's about all I can do I don't know
how to change it took me two seasons to
learn how to act I said oh okay I
supposed to cry right here I think you
do pretty good I mean all comedians I
mean no offense I could see you've taken
another role if you worked at it but I
don't comedians I think any comedian
that can act I'm like they're doing good
they're doing good you know what I I
remember seeing in my um my I say Rogan
please just watch my um my pilot in
Brooklyn maybe I don't really like
watching my friends still because I
don't like being judgmental I said watch
it Rogan I'm telling you just watch it
and give me your honest opinion and I
think was out in the jungle somewhere on
vacation that I could never [__]
afford because I'm telling you as he was
typing the text back to him I could hear
the rainfalls
well the [__] are you at vacationing
so and he texts back he's like this is
is nothing I was expecting a was like
this is really [__] good and and I
was like well you know you have somebody
from totally different walks of life
that I am and I and you know he gave me
his own on his opinion he was like if
somebody don't pick this up their
[__] fool and he watched it and he
gave me his feedback and I was like oh
okay we I got something here so even
after Hulu dropped it I always that
always stuck in the back of my head how
how much of a crossover this show is
it's not black or it's not white it's
just America problems what we do as an
American people human beings and so you
know
I I want to keep I I personally want to
keep the producing stuff like that
what um what are some of the challenges
you have with stuff you actually want to
say or do and then the network or or the
uh you know the the execs like we can't
do that we can't go there like what are
some of the challenges I'm gonna be t
plus or streaming so they don't say we
can't but they do push
um if you watch uh if you watch the
first uh season at the end me and my
sister Tammy Roman who plays on the show
we had a big argument a big fight
because she brought she allowed my kids
to bring drugs in the house and she's an
ex drug addict and you know I goes the
[__] off in the wrong way and they was
like oh my God we don't want to see two
black women fighting like that and I had
to tell the network I said people don't
watch this show to put a bow on [__]
this ain't regular TV they can go over
into CBS ABC or anywhere for that I said
they watch this show because they feel
what we're going through and when I slam
that doe and Tim was on the other side
of that dope crying I was on the other
side crying because I hate we hated that
episode
and people felt it and and you know the
network kind of pushed back and I said
let me be mean you hired me to be me you
didn't hire me to be you I don't give a
[__] about you being uncomfortable
so we did an abortion episode and I
think sometime I think we hit too close
to home for the execs and it [__] with
them so they don't want to be they don't
want to see it so I just told them I
said look it's it's it's authentic TV
and it's my life let me be me so we've
had a few pushbacks and we had some
stuff that we had to remove you know
which I remember we did a derogatory
episode and we were saying stuff like uh
the n-word chinks and
um you know at the time people was going
around beating on Asian people and I
wanted to say a [__] slap which is an old
term because I'm from the south and they
didn't they didn't really know what [__]
slap was I've never even heard that one
exactly
I didn't even know it was racist okay
because I grew up in the inner city of
Atlanta my mom said get out here for a
jab slap your ass didn't know it was
racist until my husband told me it was
so when we was doing this derogatory
episode we put everything in there and I
said well we can say [__] but we can't
say [__] slap what kind of [__] is this
so they made us change into chinks and
I'm like chinx is worse I I want to say
it is too I'm gonna say it I'm like what
are y'all talking about so we ended up
changing the words to cheeks it was just
isn't that aired yes it acted and people
loved the episode because it was saying
how I'm 50 years old but I got kids and
they don't we're not eye to eye on what
we can say back in the day you know your
grandfather grandfather your grandfather
daddy could walk around and say the
n-word freely you're not gonna be able
to say that today and you know how old
people don't realize times have changed
but a lot of people are still stuck like
when I was taking care of my father was
down to council he'd be like I lived in
I live in an all-white neighborhood he
said these some nice crackers I say
Daddy
people ain't crackers okay
you can't jip me and somebody's like you
can't say that no you can't you can't
say what's gym they said it's a
derogatory from Gypsy I didn't know that
and now you're [__] on the Gypsies
and I'm like what that's what that is I
had no idea either no I didn't amazing
like where you grow up you don't even
know some shit's racist because everyone
is saying it freely and openly and every
kid every adult just saying it it's
because they look like you it's because
everybody look like you had y'all across
that [__] railroad track you learn
you can't say that [__] or it was racist
really even jip in your neighborhood was
racist back in the day no we said Jill
oh you did no no uh uh what what else we
we said gym so jab slabs we have never
heard that one and it's crazy because I
brought that word to the set I'll say
yeah I gotta say hey man what the [__]
is that I didn't even know it well I'm
my co-creator is a 25 year old 26 year
old young guy so you know of course he
had never heard it ever but I had to
call a few people that was around my age
I was like yeah everybody heard a [__]
slab but we couldn't you know they
wouldn't air it and it was all about
derogatory words but I was shocked
nobody had heard it but I guess it was a
southern thing because I'm born and
raised in Atlanta yeah and you gotta go
check out the episode don't be in my box
and I'm saying nothing racist I'm saying
the words that have changed over the
years that once was not offensive that's
very offensive now and the whole episode
is was I'm 50 and what I can't say which
was shocking you know which and then I
got my young kids and they're saying you
can't say no words mama and I'm like wow
okay
so it was a learning episode for all of
us I hope
I watched the video one time it was a
politician and it's so funny because
he's an older white dude but there's two
younger white kids sitting behind them
and the guys uh redneck for sure and
he's talking about his dad working with
these people he goes now you might want
to get me at twenty dollars but I'm
gonna say you ain't gonna Jew me down
and you see the two and he says it like
it's it's normal conversation he's an
old white man these two young white kids
behind him look at each other they're
like did he [__] Chad you can see him
on camera like oh [__] and then all hell
breaks loose and he's got to make an
apology for it he's that old white guy
he's like yeah I didn't know that was
offensive and they're like how the hell
did you not know that one was it because
he'd been stuck in his own world that's
right and he never came across that
railroad track so nobody somebody would
say you can't say that word that's
offensive so you know that you know that
that's why I really don't worry about
what people say you know when I'm
creating I'm like get the [__] out of my
inbox okay I know I have a younger
generation in my generation in my life
which I have my kids hey can I have a
gay daughter I talk about you know I
create a lot of content about gays
because my daughter is gay on the show
and I did a whole episode about
um him them dare and her and
I had no [__] deal I some of this I
had no idea people just go by him and
him and her and I'm like when we did
this [__] I think it's called what is it
called ginger yeah pronoun Ginger
you don't know what it is either gender
what oh identity gender something and we
did a whole episode on that show well
there's him her there's they them yes
yeah and I'm like I've been joking with
my stepson too like when you say they
how many people are coming over yeah we
got one person coming over we got 20
coming up I did a whole episode I'm not
trying to be ignorant
gender numbers yes
that's my gay daughter yes okay so we
did a whole thing on Ginger neutral and
I had never heard of that [__] and the
first thing I thought my daughter my
other daughter said I thought she said
Neutrogena
[Laughter]
y'all shampoo now so wait let me ask you
this then can we talk about that well
you're having a gay daughter what about
having a gay dog well about you like
were you right away accepting of it I
knew she was gay
eat way before
she ever said she was gay but you make a
comfortable place for her to come out
and talk to you about it or were you
well she didn't never come out and talk
she just you know she went to college
and ran off and then I was like hey are
you gay she's like yes I said come on
home you can eat [__] in Atlanta that's
a whole bunch of [__] that you can eat
and I love it as that I didn't give a
[__] I don't eat [__] I'm not gonna
tell her I don't want her to tell me not
to eat Chick-fil-A I'm quite sure [__]
don't taste like Chick-fil-A but I'm not
gonna tell her what to eat that's her
[__] mouth all I'm saying is don't
put the [__] on my table need it but
you didn't you didn't talk to her about
that until she was in her 20s damn right
College well she she never came out
until she went to college until you
asked her yeah I said are you gay but
you waited that long
I didn't give a [__] but you didn't want
to feel the need to have a conversation
about it or anything that's what I'm
saying as a parent you were like
whatever she's who she is and I don't
need to ask her no she didn't she didn't
volunteer no information I didn't ask no
Howard Edition [__] gay she the only
one in the name she's the only one in my
house one trying to get no dick
everybody else was trying to get dick
they was claiming not the one dollar on
top of the roof going down the street
sucking dick she's the only one at the
house reading gay books
that's why I tell people I said if you
don't know your child is gay [__] you
are in denial
you know I don't give a [__] what you do
it's her life it's it's I don't care are
your kids Blown Away by the upbringing
you had
well that one just who just peeked in
there she was dead when I sold the drugs
you know I kept me how people and she
pushed her brother down the street with
a dope in his pample but um is that
where you would keep it yeah in a pound
you would yeah cause a police officers
can't be searching
that's child molestation
you got to be smart when you say I love
the street rules I do I love the [__]
Criminal Mind it's one of my favorite
[__] things
you're right that no cop doing it anyway
even if a cop said you need to check
that baby's diaper you checking
[__] you fingered my baby
the [__] away from my baby you touch my
dope I'ma tell everybody you fingering
my baby
oh you like fingering babies huh oh that
is not a [__] thing you want out
there man yeah he's thinking about baby
you on but it was a Hulk it was cocaine
and I [__] the cocaine I'm talking about
his finger to winning my baby ass and I
tell my baby start crying stop crying
oh my god
um tell me the scariest uh story you
ever had of of dealing and
I mean you've been shot through the
titty I think that was the scariest for
me well no I think how'd it go through
did it go toward the chest um
up and up to my arm and out yeah I think
the scariest one time when um when um it
was uh when uh what's that drug dealer
named Paolo um Pablo Escobar Pablo
Escobar was getting all the dope in
America and um I went to go meet a guy I
was a Mexican dude at uh it was it's
craftful dollar church now before he
bought that land over there over in on
on Campbell no I think it's on
Campbellton Road I'm not for sure it's
called camel toe Road no Campbellton
okay
um I don't think it's coming to work I
can't think exactly where that but um it
was like shopping centers there so I
went to go meet him about like a half a
key with my with my partner and um at
this time I'm probably like 15 16
talking mad [__] and I'm yelling at the
Mexican and talking [__] and he just
looked at me said I will put a [__]
bullet in your head and my friends
and you know I didn't know nothing about
all that [__] that was going on I whip
[__] having them ugly ass boots on my
floor like shut the [__] up [__] and he
was like do you know who you dealing
with that's a cartel and I was like who
the [__] is a cartel I'm just trying to
sell dope to make pamper money I ain't
trying to you know go to jail for real
but I think that was the most scariest
moment once we got out there and I
realized how stupid I was and when they
say it calmly like that too they don't
even react like I'll put a bullet right
in your head you're like um
I put a bullet in your [__] head [__]
that
so that was one of the most scariest
moment I think I was like I could have
got killed that day what got you into
dealing and stuff like that at that
early age uh my kid's father uh my first
kid's father used to sell drugs and so
he ended up going to jail and I needed
rent money so I just took my welfare
chicken it's called flipping it you buy
250 for dope you cut it up you make 500.
and so I just kept going from there and
you're taking a welfare check using that
to buy the that's the first time then
you double the dope yeah and then after
that you're off and running I'm off I
was on off and running and then I ended
up back in my old neighborhood and why
not I just went to go stop to say hi to
some friends and this is when crack was
like probably not even three years in
the black community everybody was
walking around like zombies and my
friends like if only we had some crack
and I was like you need crack and he was
like yeah look at all these [__]
zombies out here I was like I got crack
and I think I sold like
I probably saw like three thousand
dollars worth of dope in like 10 minutes
damn
for you I'm like 16 oh three thousand
dollars back then at 16 that's like
thirty thousand dollars more at the time
you know I I had started to gain gain a
name in the drug business so people knew
that I had created my own little trap
and a trap is where you sell that so I
created my own little block and I was
making a [__] ton of money how many
other women back then or even women
dated drug dealers yeah I didn't date
them right but how many are selling you
you're the only female doing this well
they were women were known to hold drugs
for their boyfriend I actually sold it
though
yeah so you're like the only and you're
also a teenager you're a high school kid
are you still in school no hell no when
did you stop going to school eighth
grade eighth grade yeah I already had
two kids so yeah I was I was done by
eighth grade yeah how were you when you
had your first kid 14 14 and then your
next one at what 15. so you got two kids
as a teenager yeah 16.
before you had a license I didn't have a
license but I had a car because I was a
drug
so you needed a pair you needed a
guardian to take you to get to for the
driver's test and I didn't have anybody
so I just had crackheads teach me how to
drive
crackheads taught you how to drive yeah
Craig had taught me how to drive and
who's helping you take care of these
babies me I made a [__] ton of mine I'm
taking my own [__] self so what what
was your like what was a good week for
you uh drugs don't go about weeks girls
go by days all right uh those times I
made like 15 20 000 a day a day yeah oh
you don't need anybody to help you I
didn't need nobody did you have a nice
little place you kept away man yeah my
kids dressed nice and they went to
school right there in the Trap and you
know I took care of other people kids
and yeah I had a life
how many times you people try to rob you
uh I had a crazy baby daddy so probably
twice and what are they coming for the
drugs and the money uh they came for the
money the money yeah I really would have
thought they'd come for the drugs no
crackheads don't really rob you no other
[__] robbed
kids they just want some dope they might
steal your bomb let me be a dope but
they ain't gonna [__] put no pistol
in your face so at what age do you so 16
you got two kids and then when you
realize you start wanting out of this at
what age or do you need to get out of
this what was it really you never needed
to get out of the streets and I you know
I went to jail did some time for what uh
selling drugs you got caught yeah I did
it my my cousin hid the dope wrong and
so he issued a want for me and I got
tired of running what's wrong
uh she hid it in a place where I told
her not to put it and the police was on
the ground UPS up up up the street
looking at us so he knew exactly what
adult was
yeah he saw it all so how long did you
go I did a year a year yeah where a
Fulton County because I had other
charges pinning so I didn't go to I
didn't go down the road to prison so I
did all my time in this in this in the
county okay because I had other other
court days so they didn't want to keep
transporting me plus I had a really good
lawyer that kept me in the county
and then you get out after a year and I
text the kids out of my baby daddy
friend took the kids okay and it was the
[__] worst ever but um I I I get out
I start selling again and I'm like I'm
sick of this [__] and I just started
praying I said well I need a I need a
husband I need somebody gonna take me to
[__] away from this [__] and
popped up I went to go see a comedy show
which was Bruce Bruce you went to see
Bruce Bruce yes
[Laughter]
my friend my my brother baby my brother
baby mama took me and she knew my
husband brother and we all just went out
and I was like hey I'm hiring for a baby
daddy I didn't tell him I'm hiding for
baby daddy and so I'm like hey he wasn't
really my type but I jumped on it we've
been together 31 years that's the same
guy same guy no she is yeah after a
Bruce Bruce show well we started he like
he would come over and visit and stuff
and at the time I was moving in I was
moving from selling drugs to check
forgery and so my husband oh I love that
you're moving yeah you know when one
thing playing careers you gotta shift
careers if not you get [__] up
and so
I'm moving the check for what you didn't
know I'm cleaning them and stuff are you
doing all that no no no I was uh
personal checks we would [__] you up oh
okay you just take their checkbook yeah
I had a friend that um I had you you
just get them from crackheads and people
break yeah you gotta you just buy checks
all the time so I ended up getting the
checks and um I'm now I'm forging checks
and [__] like a fool and I meet this man
he was like what the [__] are you into
and he was like do you know what you
doing those people checks I said what do
you I I'm making money he's like uh you
[__] up their lives I'm like you
don't know them he's like and you don't
either and he just sat me down and he
explained to me he's like uh what's
gonna happen to you if you go back to
jail think about your kids you want a
man to have your kids
and I remember throwing away my dopes
and my chick and I said I'm going to get
a regular job and I remember getting
hired at McDonald's said this [__] sucks
this [__] sucks come from drugs to
McDonald's oh my God I [__] hated it
I hate it but I just I stuck in it
because I didn't I didn't want my kids
to end up where I was and I had such a
good man who was willing to stick by me
you know and help me and so I got after
I got my sister key I mean I thought I
thought got him got married I ended up
getting custom my sister kids which man
mind you this man ain't got no kid but
right out the back he got six
[__] kids because I had two and
I got custody my sister four
and we just never look back do you two
have children together I have two with
him yeah with him so you have four total
I have four total so what was it about
this man
sitting you down and explaining this to
you that resonated with you because you
go from being a street Hustler to
listening to this person tell you about
these strangers you don't give a [__]
what would hit you
what made you listen to that he was a
good man and and why why do you say that
based on what like he was respectful he
had a job he was educated he had side
teeth
yeah he had everything I mean you know
he won he won no Thug he want no [__]
idiot he was like and what what really
attracted well he didn't go to college
he was in military he had just got out
of the military he was just something
that I wasn't used to you know when you
that while you used to me as treating
you a certain type of way you know and
he just he didn't bring none of that to
the table but also there's something in
you that could easily be like hey go
[__] [__] off with that [__] what
I'm saying what what I was tired and I
didn't want to get killed and leave my
kids with and I know the daddy wants
[__] and leave my kids getting bumped
around everywhere
so
um I just started when I got with him I
just started thinking about my when I
did that time in jail in jail I really
it really opened my mind to what I was I
was handing my kids the same thing my
mama handed me same thing my mom my
Grandmama handed her generation of curse
and I was like I can't do this to my
[__] my kids you know I had been
molested I had been treated wrong and I
didn't want any of that to happen to my
kids and I remember my daughter went to
college she was like everybody got a
child everybody was molested except me
and I remember thinking yes I did my job
I protected this [__] out of her but I
think I protected to so much she turned
gay you ain't gonna get no dick okay
Mama I eat a click I forgot to say Don't
eat [__] while I was Raising all that
hell
that was totally focusing don't don't
you get no dick dick don't you get no
dick I was just focusing on dick and
forgot to say Don't eat [__] so she's
like well you say don't do this so I'm
gonna go over here and jump over here in
the vagina there's no quick fix for
anxiety and depression it's not finding
a new therapist or starting an exercise
routine it's not more in regular
meditation or a better diet sometimes
you need something to unlock your brain
like a new way of thinking about and
seeing the world maybe that thing is
guided ketamine therapy from mind Bloom
there is a new tool to improve your
mental health at home ketamine therapy
mind Bloom is the leader in at home
ketamine therapy having safely helped
thousands of people overcome their
anxiety and depression unlike
traditional talk therapy ketamine Works
quickly and doesn't have the unpleasant
side effects of traditional
antidepressants in a study of over 1 200
mind Bloom clients 89 reported
improvements in their anxiety and
depression after only two sessions right
now mind Bloom is offering my listeners
a hundred dollars off your first six
session program when you sign up at
mindbloom.com Honeydew and use the promo
code honeydew take the first step and
break free from your anxiety and
depression with mind Bloom mindbloom.com
honeydew and make sure you're using the
promo code honeydew if you're trying to
improve your health hydration is a great
place to start and liquid IV is
dehydration brand that fuels your
well-being with just one stick you get
two times faster hydration and water
alone and it's so convenient you can use
it first thing in the morning you can
use it before a workout or when you feel
run down after a long night out and on
Long flights
um look I just started physical therapy
I'm taking my water bottle every day
with liquid IV in it we have it here at
the studio
putting in my drinks here on the table
just water over here you know that
contains five essential vitamins B3 B5
B6 B12 and vitamin C it has three times
the electrolytes of traditional sports
drinks and it's made with premium
ingredients non-GMO and free from gluten
dairy and soy boy so grab your liquid IV
and bulk nationwide at Costco or you can
get 20 off when you go to liquid iv.com
and use code honeydew it checkout that's
20 off of anything you order when you
shop better hydration today using promo
code honeydew at liquid iv.com now let's
get back to the do so tell me about your
you say it's a generational curse tell
me about your upbringing with your mom
and stuff before we get into quitting
school in eighth grade and dealing what
is that like are you also in Georgia
then I'm out yeah born and raised uh my
mom was an alcoholic and um uh she was I
never I've never really dealt with
depression I've seen depression and my
mom was depressed her whole [__] life
all she did was cry and my kids get on
me like you so like I'm not I'm not I'm
not a very affectionate person I love
you but I want you all over me and I
think it come because all I seen this
lady do was cry and tears to me shows
weakness okay and I would just remember
my mama crying all the [__] time I
like this [__] hell God damn can't you
hold back these tears anytime and she
cried about the same thing oh your step
daddy left me and as I got older I
realized why the Step Daddy left her
she's never on no job all she did was
drink and plus he had just bought her a
brand new false teeth and the [__] ran
him over he had them teeth on layaway
for six months you said teeth yeah
cause she got mad and said [__] these
teeth [__] and put them up on her wheel
and bagged up on them honest to God and
he looked like he was crushed like the
teeth
he was like yeah
he was like [__] I spent all my money
had he teeth on
teeth
so he left after that he's like [__]
[__] I'm out here you're gonna forever
have that hole in your mouth and so he
left
and you're just growing up with a
depressed Mom are you an only child no
it's five of us oh man she's crying all
day long she cried a lot and you know we
pretty much raised ourselves and your
dad's not around at all no no my mom was
39 years old when she passed away whoa
that's really young but if you saw her
you would think as a and it's kind of
let's be honest hard to tell black
people age but you thought she was about
60s is that the alcohol like this I mean
just constant drinking just depression
never happened but was the funniest
[__] ever seen in my life and I
think that's how I became funny when I
tell you this lady was [__] hilarious
hilarious now that I think that I said I
should have she was in a wheelchair I
should have I should have pushed that
[__] to the comedy club we would have
been Rich
my baby she had some stories for your
ass
but I didn't know it was a comedy club
she was hilarious but in the same time
we'll tell you a story and then just bus
I cry I'm like don't stop [__] crying
she's never happy
and then what age are you on your own
uh 14. I had my first child I moved out
and is she gone at that point I'm not a
little behind her okay I got me an
appointment with my welfare check my
baby daddy's drug dealer so he still
enjoyed back then the rent was 200 off
for apartment or two three hundred
dollars paid my rent and [__]
[__] had more holes in the wall
than anything but it was mines
and then what next for you you get you
meet this man this good man I meet him
and uh and then do you get out of the
neighborhood do you guys move oh yeah we
moved into we moved together into
apartment and um in Atlanta still in
Atlanta and we just started to make a
life for ourselves and I started you
know little odd jobs here and there and
he uh he worked at Simmons mattress and
eventually he got I got on that journal
I worked at General Motors and I was
like excuse me I said this [__] ain't
for me I talk too [__] much work
around these old ass drunk people
[__] up these calls we buying where
they all working drunk and [__] yeah so
when they got a union so you can't find
them I loved it no wonder our cars are
all [__] up
so I ended up um I ended up working at
General Motors he get that General
Motors he get on permanent and we got a
life and then I started some other [__]
and I got into comedy how what makes you
finally say I'm done with this [__]
I want to go do try this but that night
you went and saw that Bruce Bruce show
did something get no comedy was not on
my list because uh it was Bill Clinton
creating the welfare to work program and
I went through a hope the whole program
in a caseworker thought I was very funny
and she just kept saying you did it yeah
you did I'm like [__] get away from me
and I I did it how old were you then I
was uh probably 20 okay
maybe 21. she's like you should go try
this uh-huh and I got on stage and I
tried enough where where's your first
time the pub it was a place called The
Pub in Atlanta over there in um Morrow
Georgia and I just went up and did it
and I was like this it I can do this
[__] so I just I I went and bought a
whole bunch of Richard Pryor [__]
because my neighbor out of neighbor next
door neighbor said you remind me of
Richard Pryor all these crazy ass
stories and so he said I'm telling you a
Storyteller so I didn't know nothing
about comedy I bought all of Richard
Pryor [__] about all of Bill Cosby [__]
because I wanted to see how they tell
stories and I was like oh
I am similar to I do tell a lot of you
know crazy stories Like Richard and I
just studied the [__] out of Richard
Pryor I ain't nowhere as good as he is
but uh he taught me how to tell stories
me too yeah that's where I listen to I
mean I still there'll be at least once a
year I'll go back and listen to his
audio just in the dark and I can feel
like I'm in that room he's talking about
this cat over here with the hat on his
head and I see that guy you know what I
mean like his vet he paints a picture
that I only aspire to be able to do if
you're you know yeah man he's crazy good
well was obviously I think that's that's
my personal favorite too Richard Pryor
and you know talking about his mom being
a prostitute and his dad he grew up in a
bronx
that's what I'm saying you don't it's
not like you don't have similar
parallels as well but this is a man in
the 70s telling these stories yeah yeah
and yeah 60s and 70s I still watch uh
Richard Pryor live in concert you watch
it's 1979 at long Convention Center that
was the key and he's talking about
everything that you could it's Timeless
you could lift it up and put it into our
society today and it's the cops beating
black people it I mean everything right
there that we've all watched now
everybody just has a camera yeah you
know what I mean it's been true it's
been true it's been true now everybody's
got a camera to see it and you could
lift that up and put it I think it's the
greatest stand-up special ever it
probably is yeah that's the one I saw I
saw Bill uh Cosby live one time it was
just smooth it's two hours I've seen in
my life and I remember telling my
friends like Bill cos I'm gonna piss me
the [__] out he's like what's wrong I
said I paid all I paid the money to see
this [__] he did 45 minutes 45
minutes my friend's like [__] we've
been here for two hours we've been here
for two hours
two [__] hours yeah it's a long time
and and he just took me on it's like he
held my hand and read a book to me or
took I was in every scene with him every
story he told it was really [__] good
that's when you know I mean that's when
you know a comic really work at their
technique
you know a lot of people take this [__]
for granted but it's it's 90 percent
working on your Technique and I tell
people all the time I said don't worry
about the money the money gonna come if
you if you work on your [__]
technique and you work on your craft
the money gonna come it will it will
this takes a long time but it will
yeah it takes I mean the real money
takes a minute you can't you can't do
this
for money no if you're getting into
comedy thinking I'm gonna make a bunch
of money and that's your goal you're not
gonna make [__] you're gonna be out of
here yeah
you sure [__] will you you just
really have to just um do it because you
love it like I love standing me too I
love it I mean there have been days I'll
be at home and I'm going to get on
[__] stage and you know and people
like look up you're an open mic you got
them right on my open mic
when I'm not busy and if I take some
time off I will go hit the open mic to
work out whatever I want to do but it's
very addictive it's something that I
really [__] love to do so can we talk
about two things you said you grew up in
a bootlegger home I want to talk about
that and I also want to talk about
addiction for you I ain't been addicted
to [__] comedy though you got an
addiction to cons oh oh comment because
a lot of people think because I was a
crack dealer I was on dope
that's the number one rule well I don't
know what the rule was the [__] I saw
they was turning black people into
zombies when crack came out it's dried
out all the [__] Jerry curls I wasn't
using that [__] you blame a crack on
that
I love you baby crackling Jerry curls
are a big deal back here today hell yeah
everybody had juicy hair yeah
look wet but it was dry that's what he
always likes
everybody had a [__] dog
dry Jerry curl with crack came up with
no goddamn crack a black woman looking
like zombies and [__] that's what these
pills are today I'm watching people just
walk down the street and they stop and
fall asleep and I'm like how do you do
those pills and that heroin and [__] and
just [__] sleep standing up like that
and keep going that's your motivation I
mean who would take something that would
eat their teeth out in two weeks
he's like what the [__] happened to your
teeth Sarah I don't need no teeth uh yes
you do [__] yeah you do yes you do you
ain't gonna never eat corn on the cob
again so comedy's your addiction then
yes you and you get it
I think I get it I put all these
crackheads have that jonesing for it
like I I'm the same way this is great
this is great but we'll we'll release
this in a week or whatever so you don't
have that that instant gratification
that you do on stage I'm saying this and
these people are laughing right now and
hearing it all right now you know that's
the thing for me that's the drug of
stand up for me is that instant reaction
you and I are reacting in here but
that's different than a room full of
hundreds of people yes laughing at what
you say and good or bad that reaction's
immediate people don't like this episode
we don't know about that for a week
they don't like this set I'm doing right
now they're [__] billing me right
there at the seat you know what I mean I
love that's what I love about stand up
you know I I that's what I love it about
it too I also love that you can take I
love how I can take two to three hundred
people in a room and control them with
my voice you know what I'm saying all my
words and what I'm taking them on this
ride and I work really hard to paint
this picture because I have this little
thing I say at the top of my set come on
white people I'm about to take you on a
negro field trip
and you can already see him in their
mind putting on their seat belts and
they ready to go through the hood
because they got Miss Pat leading them
they gonna be safe and I just take them
through you know areas of my life and I
tell these stories of you know these
situations that I've been in and they
they right there with you laughing ready
to cry ready to fight and that's what I
love about stand up and then when I'm
done I can say good night and say get
the [__] out of my car and everybody go
home yeah
now tell me about growing up in a
bootlegging household you said
my granddad is so moonshine so my
brother's so moonshining you know in
this house it was just
everything went down you know uh I did
it on my special from prostitution to
gambling it was nothing that we didn't
see his kids nothing was off limits
nothing when I tell you the thing that I
remember the most about living in this
bootleg house now is I used to ask
myself why the [__] do my granddaddy put
a car change around his refrigerator one
of them things that you told another car
with yeah
around the refrigerator
I can't cause he said he would say you
[__] Ain't gonna get cold water so I
say you [__] can have cold
water
now that I got older I realize he kept
his moonshine in the refrigerator also
and my grenade kept his money and his
pistol in the refrigerator so if you try
something oh he popped that lock that
[__] chain hit the ground he'll
shoot the [__] I sure
you got a few seconds to run oh he's
getting that chain
he kept a change around that got the
refrigerator you thought that
refrigerator was in jail
he locked that [__] up all the time
can you imagine as a parent now your
kids seeing what you saw growing up oh
my kid's a bunch of [__] they beat him
call the police on me
oh mama got that refrigerator locked up
you're damn right because back in those
days kids didn't get fat you ain't what
nobody fat you took your ass outside you
rant you played him [__] house
video game you look up these
[__] got four chins on their ass
you would think the generation cause I'm
50 in a couple weeks I'm your generation
we were the ones where the video games
first came out you would think yeah you
think we'd be the ones that were super
addicted to it but we balanced it we'd
be going out all day no let me say
something to you do you remember the
[__] Atari yeah it was one little Dot
and that was football and you you had to
play them dies that [__] was so [__]
confusing if you gave these kids that
they would beat these [__] out of you
nobody but I'm saying the excitement of
this video game era we are we're at the
beginning of it we didn't have much but
I'm saying you would think we'd be the
ones that would get addicted to this new
thing that's coming in we were always
out riding the bikes that's what I'm
saying they don't do that it wasn't that
interesting either yeah you had that
little dot do you hit the football game
and that's all you had was football yeah
have you ever seen Grand Theft Auto I
was watching my kids rape a [__] wanna
I said you do not [__] hoes and don't
pay them
so you know
you know this [__] is like watching I
saw my son playing a video game before
he could play he had to watch a whole
movie on what was going the [__] on my
stepson does that I'm like what are you
watching right now I'm watching these
people play it I said what you're
watching no no not play no before before
he get to play in between each player
whatever it shows you the movie of
what's going on what about happened they
meet up they talk and I said this is a
good ass movies I'm on this video again
I said they turn that [__] off
you know
so it's it's much better now so you
can't you really can't blame them I was
just telling somebody today I said I
don't think these kids gonna know how to
ride bicycles in 10 years because they
got these little hoverboards and [__]
you ain't got to move your body no more
these [__] gonna be so stiff by
the time they get 45 they're gonna be
[__] walking they're gonna be on
canes I feel like that now with the cars
and the cameras and [__] I can't
remember the last time I put my arm
behind the seat look back to back up I'm
looking here on this camera now now my
daddy was 70 years old and I remember
one time I told my daddy back the car
but he's like I said he usually cam he
said okay [__] see on that
camera why y'all got a [__] TV here
trying to tell me what to do that Monday
you throw his whole head back to back up
yeah he would not get into that camera
yeah he would not get into that [__]
um tell me this tell me some of the
biggest challenges you have as like a
parent
um growing up the way you grew up and
the way you were parented what did you
say I said what are some of the biggest
challenges you've had as a mom as a
parent in growing up the way you grow up
and now you're trying to teach your kids
not saying the things that my mama said
that was hurtful I I've said them before
but I have to catch myself like [__]
and you know cussing them out and I
still cuss him out but not as harsh as
my mama did with us she make it personal
very very get your ugly ass out of here
really yeah I was always called ugly
ugly yeah so
um I would uh I I started off in the
beginning and my husband I remember my
husband having to talk with me like hey
your words is Gonna Last way longer than
a ass whooping you might want to watch
what you say
man you got a good man he's a pretty
good man where's where'd he like how'd
he come up because he grew up in his
daddy worked for the city his mom but
somebody cared enough about him to say
these things to him well he had a good
family he was 16 of them so yeah that's
a big family too yeah very very big
family very Christian fight and you know
he grew up he grew up probably like
Leave it to Beaver yeah yeah
so he had a he came from a very good
background
and again you listen to that yes I do it
resonates with you it did yeah and it
still do I'm still with him I wouldn't
try to say 30 years right you said 30 31
years I mean that's a hell of a long
time
yeah you must love them I do some days
someday I won't kick his [__] ass but
what's uh all right so he's dropping
some knowledge and some lessons on you
what are somewhere you've taught told
him like oh yeah well how about this and
he's like okay I think I've taught him
uh
Street knowledge I don't think he was I
don't think he was smart in that Street
area like I am like when when the
[__] go down I speak the [__] up my
husband ain't gonna complain he gonna
like Yay you know but me now I'm ready
to fight about everything and you know I
know [__] I'd be like come on you
can't see this [__] you know my
husband's taking as your word I'm like
no this [__] is trying to rob us
so it's that kind of [__] yeah
is that me me being more aware of the
[__] than he are yeah
what um all right so you have four kids
have you raised each one of them
differently I imagine you've had to you
had the first one at 14 then you said 16
15 and 16. the first two I call them my
Medicaid kids
caught my second took my blue crop Blue
Shield kids so yeah they the second two
daddy raised the first two kids so if
you watch the show you'll see a lot of
that in it
that's a good point yeah he did raise
their brothers or was uh you have boy
and girl a boy girl I have a girl boy
girl boy okay yeah and he raised all
four of those kids all four of them damn
yes he did it's a lot and and then help
with your sisters for a little while too
then I got custody of my niece kids
right now
and how is he as a stepdad versus a dad
he's not a stepdad he's just everybody
today okay all right so he's jumping
he's good with it yeah everybody's dead
and how is he as a father great yeah
yeah he's better than me as a mama you
think so for real or are you just joking
oh you got a lot more patience
don't talk to the babies like that
[__] them
laughs
uh what's the hardest part about
marriage for you
uh
hardest part about marriage is um
it's it's a man it's work
I mean 31 years tell me about that you
got to keep working to stay in love you
because you've gone from I mean I hear
some people get divorced I'm like that
that's why you're getting divorced over
that you guys have gone from
the streets this is well he wasn't in
the streets I was going out of the
streets yeah from the struggle to to now
we've been through a lot and but now
also entertainment and growing in comedy
over the years and supporting that like
this he supported a lot of my [__]
that's a lot that's a sh that's a you
know one and I don't know what chance to
someone makes themselves successful at
stand-up comedy at your level and he's
supporting you doing that he wanted me
to quit in the beginning but I'll say
something here I want to keep going what
was it he wanted you to have the
stability of like this yeah and he's
like hey this is a lot of [__] money
I was like hey I don't need that I don't
know insurance so you go do it and we're
still having it
one is enough and so I wanted he would
have did it and I did stand up it took
off guess what he retired last year did
he really yeah how old is he now he's
50. hell yeah he retired uh eight years
early that's nice yeah so I was like hey
you can retire now we're good let's go
wow yeah he put all that time into and
gets to retire user how is he doing with
retirement is he he seems like a worker
though at least he's the one we're doing
another house so we um so he's got
projects He got projects but he get on
my [__] nerves sometimes he really do
because he he gets bored and he done by
like a five thousand dollar drone I'm
like what the [__] are you gonna do
today
please put in the air can't get it down
five thousand dollars when I know that
you know he don't calm down a lot but he
just he enjoying retirement you know he
said at the house he he's good he's good
tell me
some of the stuff you miss about the
Streets back in the day
ah nothing nothing at all
um
no because I lived a life so all that
party and [__] was out of me by the time
I was 19. I'd already did it all
God all of it by 19. yeah about 19 20. I
was done still a baby yeah but I was
ready to be settle down and just have a
life how did you relate to other kids
your age I thought it was stupid yeah
because I was a mom did you have any
friends at all at that age that that you
connected with back then yeah we was
hanging in this all my friends was older
too like I'm 50 now my friends are 60.
okay I see so that's all 10 years old
yeah a lot of my friends was way older
than me I was the only [__] that was
too young to get in the club
I was always with the fake ID everybody
else was the right age right so you know
by by the time I started to get married
they started to get married so we was
all settled down together I see so some
kids your age were just like now yeah
you don't even know what's going on out
they were stupid to me like you know why
you're not working why you been an
[__] you know but I was off with a
husband and a family so I couldn't
understand why they was being kids
because it was [__] kids they were
supposed to be having the time of their
lives right but I already had the time
of my life when I was [__] in
elementary and middle school yeah and
they're all just getting started yeah I
was just getting started the right way
yeah right the right way
um oh I just had a question I really
wanted to ask you now
[Music]
um
I don't remember now damn it I rarely
forget my questions
I do want to know
you know you're
well how were you when you got married
like officially married 19. oh damn no
I'm sorry I'm sorry 20. gosh so you knew
you did everything fast you're married
with children by 20 years old uh we
bought our first time I can't even 25
legally he could I couldn't wow but our
first house was 25
uh ended up moving out to Indiana when I
was uh in my early 30s
and why there why'd you guys go to
Indiana General Motors closed in Atlanta
oh I see we spent 15 years out there
yeah I was saying when I met you I feel
like you were out there
I probably was yeah years ago I met you
and you were in Indiana so I was there
like 15 16 years and now I'm back in
Atlanta what do you like better
I'm born and raised that's my city yeah
yeah any of them to White for me
is it yeah I need to go places where
it's kind of still divided it I wouldn't
say it's racist it's just how the city
just cut up you know I lived in a place
called Plainfield Indiana and when I
would tell black people yeah I know
Playing Field Indiana yeah I sure do I
got Ah that's crazy a girl at the time I
was dating in high school her family
moved to Plainfield Indiana her dad got
a job out there and you know we're all
still friends it was her and her sister
and they just I just went to
Indianapolis and she and her husband and
her sister all came out helped me sell
merch we all hung out but Plainfield I
took a Greyhound from Baltimore to play
Plainfield Indiana it was not easy so
yeah
[__] and and I tell black people I
lived there they was like why uh the
school system good [__] and it's
a nice neighborhood and so you know
black people lived on that side and then
you it's almost like the biracial people
lived in another part of the city and
then you had us you know over here and I
was like y'all to the valley Atlanta
separates You by money
now I call them money I see okay you
have a rapper living next door to
[__] uh a [__] Governor
imagine you know money separates you and
I just said that was kind of I didn't
like that
you know we go anywhere live in Atlanta
we don't give a [__]
and you you got to get recognized a lot
in Atlanta now
I do yeah I get recognized a lot I the
whole Fame thing I hate is the whole now
I gotta put my wig on right and put on
makeup I can't ask your Feats no more I
can't just run to Walmart yeah I can't
just throw some flip-flops
I ran to Sam the other day and everybody
like give me let me get a picture let me
get a picture I said never [__] again
imma make sure I have my [__] together
yeah yeah so that's the [__] I hate
about Fame cause I just can't look any
kind of way
oh my God
how about
um relatives you got relatives that
support and come out nothing what about
siblings are you close with your
siblings no everybody just had to grow
up differently and fend for themselves
back then or what pretty much I mean my
I got a brother in jail one in North
Carolina I don't really deal with I kind
of when I made my own family
that's what I did you made a big one
though I do I have a pretty big family I
have some really good friends in my life
do you still have your sister's kids
no my sister got him back when I had
about 11 years they got on dope and then
now I got one of my sister kids kids
so I got my sister grandkids God and
I've had them for going on 10 years man
how many people you've been taking care
of a lot yeah you've got four of your
own kids
I have four adopted kids and then I have
uh that's who's in the house now but my
kids are grown yeah but they weren't but
they weren't with the other kids but
they are now so it's just me I have an
older daughter that's 24 and in the four
adopted kids who's the youngest 24 my my
youngest is a 22 year old boy and he's
Homer he's gone too ah he's home how do
you feel about everybody being grown and
stuff do you miss all them being around
are you really we do a lot together as a
family so I don't really know you got
your girls here now yeah my daughter's
here
yeah I'm always traveling with somebody
this I listen you're such a fascinating
person thank you I mean you really are
you're
first of all the fact that you're not
dead after all that [__] is amazing I
know you know let me [__] up and God
gave me cancer
it really is amazing the numbers the
stats on you getting out of there alive
number one is a big thing two getting
out of there alive and making something
of yourself is a big deal you ever think
about that I try not to it's worked it
is I try not to think about
uh the things I accomplished how do you
do that when you're including these sort
of story lines in your sitcom and stuff
does that do you ever have a moment like
man you really read that or hear someone
else say a line you're like man I live
that are you ever have that moment no
because I just look at I I put everybody
I put everything in a category called
work
so even though the sitcom is 90 of my
life I don't look at me as being the
star of it I look I tell them we all
stars it take all of us even the people
behind the camera to make this [__] work
but I mean is there a moment like with
another actor on the set or something
where they write you you say no this is
how it went down and then you hear it
come back to you well when we writing it
and then when we act it out yes there's
been time I [__] must start crying
yeah there have been times
um you know
we had to move some things around but
yeah yeah I feel it all the time but as
far as what I accomplished I just look
at everything as being worked I don't
you know I don't put no chip on my
shoulder I don't I try to stay as humbly
as possible I'm just grateful I'm
thankful and I just want people to know
you know it I tell them and we heard
this a thousand times for years it's not
about how you start it's about how you
finish so you know I try to uplift
people like hey you looking at somebody
who who was just thrown away by society
and when you get up and you make up your
mind that you want to do something for
yourself
and then you can do it that's it right
there that's the truth I've been that's
what this whole show is about just being
thrown away and thrown away and thrown
away and then you just got to get your
ass up and go do it and that's what
happened when you get up and go do it
you're fine and you're gonna be okay you
know yeah yeah you know
I tell everybody the first step
to accomplish anything in life is to
learn how to love yourself
when you put yourself first and you can
learn how to love yourself then
everything else will fall into place but
you cannot accomplish anything when you
putting other people before you and when
you don't love yourself when I started
to love myself
I told everybody else kiss my ass
I wasn't searching for friends anymore I
wasn't searching for love anymore all of
that stuff came into my life the right
way it wasn't being forced
so the first key to anything I would say
is to love yourself
it's been a great episode I could talk
to you forever I'm curious about how
you're going to answer this question
though and then I'm gonna let you get
out of here we're gonna promote
everything one more time okay what
um now knowing what we've talked about
especially your age too with everything
that happened uh what advice would you
give to your 16 year old self
uh if I could give advice to my 16 year
old self I would look back and say I'm
so glad we didn't give up
[__] yeah don't give up yeah I'm so glad
we didn't give up I mean also know this
too like and and a lot of young people
ask me this too but part of it is just
staying in the [__] game you gotta
stay in the game you can't quit and it
can't take no break no you know
um you know without it with all the [__]
that was thrown at me at the kitchen
you'd have thought so many times I
wanted to quit or I should have quit
but I didn't quit yeah and look where
I'm at today that's right I'm glad you
didn't good for you thanks for doing
this thank you thank you for having me
you're the best
um promote everything one more time
please please go to misspackcomedy.com
for tour tickets I'm getting ready to
start a theater tour hell yeah uh in the
fall also make sure you watch the third
season of the Miss Pat Show on BET plus
and Amazon Prime now if you if you're
not familiar with the Miss Pat show you
can always start from season one cause
it's three whole season for you to
[__] watch so make sure you do that I
also have a podcast called the pat down
with Miss Pat so make sure y'all check
me out on uh my own podcast called the
pat down all right thank you for doing
it thank you as always ryansickler.com
Ryan sickler on all social media we'll
talk to you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]